france 2022 l'heure du choix à quoi deux
semaines et demi maintenant à l'élection
présidentielle du premier tour albert
louis précisément j'ai moins 18 ans
raphaël avant le premier tour de la
présidentielle et le candidat d'extrême
droite eric zemmour a présenté
aujourd'hui son programme très détaillé
sans surprise sur la politique
migratoire suppression du droit du sol
fin des aides sociales pour les
étrangers extra-européens fin du
regroupement familial
eric zemmour qui fait par ailleurs
l'objet d'une nouvelle plainte six
associations anti homophobie l'accusent
de contestation de crime contre
l'humanité pour avoir nié la déportation
des homosexuels pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale dans son livre paru en
septembre le récap politique est signée
florent rondeau et nicolas ouvert
c'est l'histoire d'un double message à
limoges françois hollande est venu
soutenir une anne hidalgo qui en a bien
besoin mais pas que
l'ancien président socialiste l'a acté
la gauche ne gagnera pas dans un mois
compter sur lui pour la suite
rémy quoi qu'il advienne le 10 et 24
avril prochains
une initiative devra être prise au
lendemain du scrutin et avant les
élections légistatives
pour reconstruire la bouche de
responsabilité
lui aussi veut reconstruire non pas la
gauche mais la france
l'ambitieux communiste fabien roussel
entend convaincre bien au-delà du simple
monde ouvrier
je m'adresse à tous les français il y en
a tellement qui ont été déçus qu'on
retient coup à gauche un coup à droite
et qu'il ne s'y retrouve plus moi je
veux reconstruire la france avec tout le
monde mais c'est une différence de
taille avec les autres forces de gauche
sans hégémonisme sans sectarisme
du côté d'eric zemmour journée chargée
nouvelles plaintes de plusieurs
associations anti homophobie et
présentation de ses 400 mesures pour la
france de demain la france est à la
croisée des chemins de sa propre
histoire économiquement culturellement
démographiquement notre pays pourrait
s'effacer progressivement de la grande
marche du monde nos programmes est là
pour conjurer cette fatalité
la veille le candidat de reconquête
était en terrain conquis un débat
organisé par l'hebdomadaire d'extrême
droite valeurs actuelles ou valérie
pécresse a été légèrement hués
[Musique]
même pas peur
quand on est tenu neuf mois face à la
rue face aux étudiants gauchistes et
qu'on a fait 70 évacuation de fac on n'a
pas peur de venir débattre il n'y a pas
que les électeurs que les prétendants à
l'elysée tente de caresser dans le sens
du poil soutenu par brigitte bardot
nicolas dupont aignan est désormais lui
aussi l'ami des animaux
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
[Musique]
voilà et puis le bras de fer se poursuit
entre yannick jadot et total energy le
groupe français attac même le candidat
écologiste à la présidentielle en
diffamation après qu'il a accusé le
groupe de complicité de crimes de guerre
pour le maintien de ses activités en
russie malgré la guerre en ukraine des
propos inacceptables pour le pdg patrick
pouyanné qui affirment continuer ses
opérations d'achat de gazeuse pour le
bénéfice des consommateurs européens
1 le gaz russe et la dépendance
énergétique de la france se sont donc
naturellement imposée 1 comme des thèmes
de campagne oui effectivement on en a
déjà beaucoup parlé de la flambée des
cours du gaz du pétrole en lien avec la
situation en ukraine ce qui pèse on l'a
vu sur le pouvoir d'achat des français
on va voir maintenant comment se
positionnent les candidats à la
présidentielle sur cette question avec
marina berges bonsoir marina commandes
on se positionne les candidats sur la
question des importations d'énergie
fossile russe alors déjà ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que jamais une crise
internationale n'avait autant percuté la
scène politique française parce qu'elle
nous parle en réalité
d'environnement cette crise ukrainienne
également en france elle nous parle de
questions très quotidienne prix de
l'énergie question du pouvoir d'achat et
c'est pour ça que l force une réflexion
à long terme sur l'indépendance
énergétique de la france alors on a fait
un trombinoscope avec les positions des
différents candidats effectivement sur
votre question faut-il boycotter les
hydrocarbures russes la première chose
que vous devez noter h rennes c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de points
d'interrogations ils sont très peu à
s'être prononcée parce que c'est une
question éminemment polémique quatre
candidats sont contre deux candidats
seulement milite pour un boycott
énergétique de la russie le reste on ne
sait pas trop alors les pro boycott a eu
aucune surprise là dessus
yannick jadot candidat europe ecologie
les verts sans aucune ambiguïté 700
millions de dollars entre tous les jours
dans les comptes de poutine qui finance
la guerre il faut bloquer cet argent
pour la socialiste anne hidalgo il faut
aller jusqu'à un embargo sur le gaz
russe et elle précise le plus rapidement
possible même argument que yannick jadot
en réalité ils sont sur la même longueur
d'onde payer pour le gaz russe est bien
ça revient à remplir les caisses de
vladimir poutine et donc la guerre alors
de l'autre côté on a les anti boycott et
ils sont bien plus nombreux vous avez
d'abord marine le pen vous savez qu'elle
est souvent accusée d'être proche de
vladimir poutine alors elle est dans une
position délicate et elle change de
sujet elle nous parle du coup de pouvoir
d'achat des français c'est son sujet
préféré un embargo sur le gaz et le
pétrole russe aurait des conséquences
que conséquences cataclysmiques pour les
français même son cloche côté eric
zemmour et jean luc mélenchon
il nous parle ou consommateurs français
qui seraient les premiers à faire les
frais de tout cela l'embargo sur le gaz
russe nous dit mélenchon ce serait une
aberration la dernière contre c'est
valérie pécresse il ne serait pas
réaliste selon elle de 1 boycotter le
gaz russe et pis alors dans cette case
grise avec ce point d'interrogation d'un
camille emmanuel macron pour être tout à
fait précis parce qu'en tant que
candidat il n'a pas fait de déclaration
publique sur cette question mais en tant
président en exercice il soutient l'idée
évidemment au niveau européen d'arrêter
l'importation d'énergie fossile russe
d'ici 2022 alors il ya une idée un en
revanche qui fait absolument l'unanimité
chez les candidats réduire la dépendance
française au gaz russe voilà pour
l'embargo effectivement mais réduire la
dépense pour française on y arrive
comment pour ses douze candidats alors
y'a pas 15 alternative y en a une toute
façon c'est soit le nucléaire soit les
énergies renouvelables et là encore les
candidats il se positionne très
différemment pour une majorité de
candidats ils sont français il faut
augmenter le nucléaire france royaume du
nucléaire emmanuel macron marine le pen
valérie pécresse tous veulent relancer
la production le président de la
république a d'ailleurs promis il ya
quelques semaines de construire des
nouveaux réacteurs 6 à 14 nouveaux
réacteurs et puis on a de l'autre côté
de l'échiquier politique
pour de nombreux candidats le nucléaire
ça n'est pas la solution pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que cette guerre
en ukraine elle pose la question de la
sécurité du nucléaire on a vu les
inquiétudes lorsque tchernobyl a été
pris par l'armée russe et puis la
question aussi c'est celle des
renouvelables évidemment avec très
clairement sans surprise là encore
yannick jadot et anne hidalgo qui ceux
qui se prononcent pour un démantèlement
progressif des centrales nucléaires
d'ici 2050 pour hidalgo et d'ici 2035
pour yannick jadot et les alterner
l'alternative c'est bien sur les
renouvelables yannick jadot nous dit
dépendre du vent du soleil et de la
biomasse vaut mieux que de dépendre de
poutine et des pétromonarchies du golfe
merci beaucoup marina pour votre
éclairage et on vous retrouvera bien sûr
dans les prochaines semaines pour parler
à de l'environnement dans cette campagne
autre actualité qui s'est interloqué
avec la campagne hexagonale cette fois
c'est la question corse oui on en
parlait la semaine dernière raphaël le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
s'était dit prêt à aller jusqu'à
l'autonomie pour la corse une
déclaration qui était intervenue après
la violente agression d'yvan colonna en
prison qui a d'ailleurs causé sa mort il
ya deux jours et après des affrontements
lors de manifestations de soutien aux
militants indépendantistes sur l'île de
beauté un regain de tension qui a donc
fait de la question corse un sujet
brûlant de cette fin de campagne maya
anaïs iata guen
à moins d'un mois du premier tour la
question corse en flammes la campagne
pour ramener le calme après deux
semaines de violences paris ouvre la
voie à un statut d'autonomie la volonté
de la république était double c'est la
corse dans la république il ne s'agit en
aucun cas d'indépendance est par contre
d'autonomie qu'on a donné à d'autres
collectivités nationales une annonce
historique dans un pays
traditionnellement très centralisé mais
qui laisse beaucoup de corps sceptiques
ce sont des promesses électorales
je ne peux pas être satisfait d'une
autonomie vague de la non reconnaissance
de notre peuple cette île montagneuse de
plus de 300000 habitants est devenue
française au xviiie siècle pendant plus
de 40 ans la corse est le théâtre de
violences séparatistes
en 2014 les indépendantistes déposent
les armes pour servir leur cause par des
voies plus pacifiques en 2018 la
collectivité de corse est créé
insuffisant pour les autonomistes qui
dirige la région et qui réclament une
meilleure reconnaissance de leur
identité notamment de leur langue
mais les négociations autour d'une
possible l'autonomie débuteront en avril
et doivent se terminer d'ici la fin de
l'année un dossier brûlant de plus sur
la table du prochain président il faut
aujourd'hui ouvrir parce que ça n'a pas
été fait dans les derniers mois ça n'a
pas été fait dans les dernières années
une nouvelle relation entre la corse et
d'état français nous avons proposé par
exemple si c'est la demande encore ce
d'introduire et de donner à la corse le
statut qu'on appelle l'article 74 qui
est l'article qui s'applique à la
polynésie française et qui permet
d'avoir davantage d'autonomie à la clé
plus de pouvoirs législatifs pour la
corse cette région l'une des plus
pauvres de france pourrait devenir
compétente en matière de fiscalité de
développement économique et de lutte
contre la spéculation foncière voilà
donc un petit point sur les candidats à
la présidentielle qui sont très divisés
sur cette question corse à gauche
l'écologiste yannick jadot se dit en
faveur d'une autonomie de plein droit la
socialiste anne hidalgo d'une autonomie
législative
le leader du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste
philippe poutou parle d'une
reconnaissance d'un statut corse à
droite maintenant se veut plus fermes la
candidate du rassemblement national
marine le pen affirme que la corse doit
rester française celle des républicains
valérie pécresse veut ramener l'ordre en
corse et ne pas démanteler la république
même ligne pour nicolas dupont aignan et
à l'instant emmanuel macron dénonce une
faute à propos des drapeaux en berne
pour yvan colonna encore au président de
la république candidat par ailleurs lui
aussi a un avis sur la question et qui
n'est pas celui des autorités locales
élues en corse voilà l puis une petite
image de faim à présent raphaël tout
autre chose pour pour finir de manière
un peu plus légère une panne de
prompteur ça vous est déjà arrivé
j'imagine je veux pas dire régulièrement
mais sa voix la scène épargne en tout
cas personne même pas les candidats à la
présidentielle qui utilise donc souvent
un prompteur pour lire leurs discours ou
leurs programmes comme j'utilise moi
même en ce moment un prompteur pour vous
lire ce journal de campagne et c'est
pour ça qu'à voir une version papier ça
peut servir eric zemmour en a fait les
frais aujourd'hui regarder
si l'épopée française dure depuis si
longtemps
c'est
cet intéressant
c'est parce que l'état
et voilà donc c'est soit on donne le
texte soit on remet le prompteur en
marche
merci à vous
je vous en prie
ah bah alors voilà on verra si c'est que
parce que l'état a su assurer ses
fonctions les plus sacrés voilà donc il
aurait dû apprendre son texte par coeur
comme quoi en france on n'a pas de
pétrole mais parfois son texte on n'a
pas non plus d'idées merci france 2022
l'heure du choix retrouver aux siens sur
notre site internet france 24 ce point
comme et bien sûr dès demain même heure
20h10 heure de paris pour france 2022
lors du choix non se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour un nouveau journal
dans paris direct